[Music]
[Laughter]
you
[Music]
how are you feeling today like roadkill
I'm sorry to hear that
would you like me to send a message to
your team to see if there's anything
they can do yes I'm glad you were able
to talk with your pharmacist and that
they adjusted your medication how are
you feeling today
better thanks Patsy it's a nice sunny
day out think you might go for what hmm
don't forget your medication and a
bottle of water
want me to set a reminder good idea
[Music]
nine eight seven six
hello and welcome everybody to Udacity
robotics QA I'm Mike Salem and I'm here
with CEO and founder of catelleya health
Cory Kidd Cory how are you I'm doing
great thanks for having me thanks for
coming by
appreciate it Lee so can you talk to us
a little bit about catelleya health I
know you know people out there have
already seen a little bit of the video
so I'm just gonna give background about
the company how you came up with the
idea certainly
so you know we think of Catania health
actually as a patient care management
company right so we're in healthcare
obviously there's a robot involved which
we're going to talk a lot about today
definitely but what we think about doing
is helping keep patients who are dealing
with some chronic condition on therapy
and out of the hospital for longer and
so we'll go into a little bit about how
and why we do that quick background I've
been in healthcare technology for about
20 years ago 20 years now so 20 years
ago I was at Georgia Tech over to
Atlanta I did an undergrad degree in
computer science okay by the time I
finished I was hired as a research
faculty helped build and run a research
lab focused on Aging in Place 2001 went
back to grad school I went up to MIT to
the Media Lab and I was there for about
6 and a half years I did my masters in
PhD in human robot interaction which is
where I started to bring in robots like
this into healthcare and the first
couple of years spent running this
series of studies looking at what
happens when we interact with a robot
not so much from a technology
perspective from a psychology
perspective and the quick summary of two
years of work and a whole bunch of
studies with a lot of people is when
we're face to face with someone that's
different than interacting with someone
virtually right the conversation that
we're having is a little bit different
than the conversation that we're having
right now right we're all kind of
together but the face-to-face part is
different then intuitively we get that
right a lot of us spend a lot of our
time in meetings with other people and
psychologically we actually know what's
happening there right we're face to face
with someone we are creating a stronger
relationship that relationship is going
to last for longer we find that person
that we're talking with be more credible
more informative more trustworthy and
what those studies showed is those
differences actually carry over into the
world of technology so put something
like this there that could actually look
you in the eyes while it's talking to
you right you start to get the
psychological effects that you're never
going to get delivering that same
interaction through a screen whether
it's text base or even a character that
just like one of our robots and so that
was really the the foundation my PhD
showed then that this stuff actually
works in the real world I did my
clinical work at Boston Medical and
endocrinology we put early versions of
the robot that's become maybe out in
patients homes a decade ago and I've
been building on that ever since oak
italia health is the latest iteration of
this a company that I started a little
over two and a half years ago to take
this technology so hardware and software
the robotics the psychology the AI and
apply it in chronic care management
interesting very cool so I know you
talked a little bit about human robot
interaction and kind of getting to a
point where people can kind of talk back
and forth and you have that sense of
bond and Trust right and doing the same
thing with a robot what were some of the
initial like complications or challenges
that you face when you were actually
doing this for the first time with
people I mean I know there's there's
issues with you know design and these
issues with mechanics as far as the
speech the cadence of the speech right
the the way words are pronounced what
were some of the things that you started
realized and kind of quickly like wow
this is a really challenging and
interesting problem so there are a lot
of them and implicitly you're getting it
the biggest problem which is you've got
to get all these things at least good
enough maybe I'm not gonna say right
right obviously that's where we try to
get to and that's a lot of what we focus
on as a company now but you've got to
get each one of those pieces good enough
to make this kind of work right so those
early studies which was more than 15
years ago now you know building these
robots by hand I can assure you they
didn't look anywhere near as refined as
this yeah right and getting them
together and being able to do the the
speech recognition right so that's
gotten much better in the last few years
but even five years ago that was not
nearly as good as what we have today
right speech output same thing right
it's simply getting better you know
we'll hear from maybe here in a second
you know you guys probably just heard
the video you know with her talking and
on both of those we license commercial
technology at Kataya health as part of
what we're doing but when you're
starting to build things you know in a
research lab like I was or on your own
like you know cobbling these pieces
together
definitely getting much easier today but
there's challenges and making them all
fit together and it kind of the right
level of fidelity in other words if this
thing you know can kind of have an okay
conversation with you and maybe is okay
at recognizing you you don't necessarily
want a human voice
it's like URI right right so then
there's kind of a disconnect so you've
got to get all these things to fit
together in the right way so you start
talking about these things I know it's
common expression uncanny valley right
so where you have a robot that's not
quite human enough to pass as human
right it's more human-like than a
typical robot so you have to find this
kind of gentle balance to kind of say
this is where I want to be or this is
where I want to be but I can't be in
this kind of threshold here because all
of a sudden it's off-putting for a lot
of people exactly right so so the
uncanny valley was originally you know
theorized to be about the appearance of
something right right you get something
totally not human on one end you get
more and more human-like and then
something that looks just like a person
right but there's this valley right
before but I think you know as you're
saying uncanny valley definitely applies
across a lot of different aspects all
right right so not only the appearance
and obviously we avoid that here right
no one's gonna mistake this for a human
right voice right you got to be good
enough to be understandable but you
don't want to sound just like a person
because that's going to cause problems
the level of conversation right if you
start off maybe you craft that first
conversation or to it just to be you
know really witty really cute right
really engaging and then someone gets
past that and they oh it's kind of this
huge drop-off right you fall into the
same trap and it's okay and you're gonna
think about it in all the different
aspects of what you're doing here yeah I
could definitely see if you felt like
hey this conversation is starting off
really normal and then all of us say you
hit this point where it's a snag even if
the voice still cut has the same type of
cadence right still kind of works in the
same way and all of a sudden the
conversation feels forced or artificial
that you're just kind of like I don't
know if I want to continue which is
where you're with a lot of chatbot
technology right right and sometimes it
works really well like wow you know this
was pretty good other times like wait a
second that's clearly not human there's
something strange there yeah and you
always want that human touch at the end
of the day yeah yeah definitely so let's
talk a little bit about the design and
how you came up with the design for me
boo so this particular robot we brought
an idea of the big design firm to help
us with the design and so we went to
them this was about two and a half years
ago now the design brief was very simple
okay three things
let's have eyes that can look at you
sure you know looking eye contact is
very important and we know that from
lots of study so that was number one
number two we need the screen right now
a lot of the the interactions through
voice conversation back and forth kind
of like talking to you know Siri or
Alexa right but we want to be able to
show stuff on the screen right for many
of our patients or might want to be able
to say alright remember when your doctor
showed you how to you know measure this
or do this let me show you that video
again right so to be able to use very
nice variation exactly and we didn't
want it too tiny all right some of our
patients are older we went a little more
realistic but it also doesn't need to be
the size of a TV right so kind of a
screen about this size and the last
thing was you know something roughly the
size of a kitchen appliance right now
just in terms of the technology we could
be we could build this to be about the
size of your cellphone sure my screen
real estate again small that something's
going to get you know tossed in a drawer
under the sofa you're going to lose it
sure right and we can also build it to
be humanoid right the size of one of us
but then it doesn't fit into anyone's
home so you know kind of somewhere in
the middle and so that was a design be
really simple and in the first week or
two kind of went off in all different
directions right all kind of crazy ideas
for what this might look like started
narrowing down started putting this in
front of potential patients and
customers and really honed in on
something like what you see here and
this was you know the exact design here
was refined over several weeks
interesting so how many design
iterations do you think you went through
for kind of putting this final design
out so I'd say you know for big picture
not that many you know probably upper
single digits low two digits that's do
that but within some of the details a
lot okay so some of the things that
we've learned over the last few years
you know how we do the eyes how you do
the smile the placement of various
pieces of it those kinds of things
require a lot more detail than say maybe
the overall shape right so within some
of those that could have even been
hundreds of iterations alright so in
some of those detailed features or the
eyes that you know you've just seen in
the video and that you'll see when we
wake her up here in a second right that
actually took a few more months until we
got the eyes right now so some of those
things take a lot more work than than
others so I have one have one question
about this in particular always kind of
wondered about is the color what was the
the idea of a yellow because you see a
lot of robotics now that are done
they're typically done in either a white
gray or black alright and this is very
unique to me because it's actually done
in a yellow color so you know we want
something that fits in
in our patients homes right black white
maybe but kind of high-tech or
industrial when we were building the
early versions of this so this is a
manufactured version the early versions
were 3d printed and hand assembled Wow
and there is a shelf in our office that
you can come see where each one of them
is a different color pick up on that by
the way and so what we were doing is you
know as I said from the very early
iterations when this was just you know
sketches and computer designs to you
know little tiny 3d printed models
testing them in front of people right
same thing with the color as we develop
more and more of them and so part of it
is okay what are the popular colors
right now what actually fits into
people's homes part of it is thinking of
this you know this is a healthcare coach
there's a certain set of colors you
might want to go with and test it out a
number of things now the reality is the
first manufacturing run is fairly small
you knows we're building these by the
hundreds now that's starting to grow but
when we're doing that mini you know we
kind of had to pick one of those colors
and yellow tested best eventually it's
going to be hey you're getting one of
these you know pick which color you want
which I color and we'll send you that
one that's very cool
so talking about a little bit more of
this design can I know this is a huge
component to a robot like that's correct
how large is the team that you had kind
of developing this so you know we were
fortunate to bring in I do two to do the
work so we have you know our team at
that point of time I could tell you help
was about five people okay and we had
another five or six I do working on this
was about ten people you know half of us
on the the healthcare and you know
robotics you member by interaction side
of it and half from the industrial
design aspect okay great and out of
these people what's like the varying
backgrounds that you would you kind of
so she and I know you have a background
human robot interaction I know they have
obviously background in design right so
was there any other components or people
that you worked with on this program
that you felt like they were really
instrumental in detrimental to your not
yet part of the team right like a really
important piece is not detrimental there
some prevail that's definitely the wrong
word yeah since our team is actually
very diverse and I think that's part of
you know the important thing about
building something like this right so
robots that are going to work in the
real world in some context right this is
not an industrial robot this is not a
research robot you know my team at that
point in time so you
my background as I talked about you know
human robot interaction both technology
and healthcare rights have done clinical
work and more technical work in AI and
psychology so bringing that together and
a lot of other you know the rest of our
team complements those types of
backgrounds right so in that early team
someone who's doing mechanical design
and fellow Media Lab alum Chris he was
doing a lot of the design of the inside
you know we had someone who with design
and user experience research background
on our team we had the person running
business development who is a former
lawyer alright so you know bringing
together a lot of different aspects of
thinking about how people are actually
going to use this right our team has
continued to grow with writers and
psychologists and clinicians
understanding the different aspects and
so while those people are not the one
you know sketching out thinking about
the design their input and you know
understanding different aspects of our
patients lives or where this fits in the
healthcare system I think are all
incredibly important to how you make
something like this you know from the
design through the implementation
getting it to work right now talking
about these people with these various
backgrounds when you consider everybody
on this team to be a robot assist at
heart or you know actual robot assist or
how do you how do you kind of see that
right because for me personally I feel
like when I talk to people and they say
well what is a robot a sister who could
be a robot a sister who is a robot
assist it's always really kind of
convoluted right because I'm like well
it's somebody you should know electrical
and somebody you should know how to code
a little bit right but there's so many
pieces and components of what actually
makes a robot that I feel like you know
various backgrounds placed so well into
certain fields and having that that's
sort of like knowledge but in that
specialization in a certain topic is
definitely you know important right yeah
so I think it really depends on how you
define that you know I don't usually try
to write you know if we take a very
strict definition you know someone who
could do the mechanical electrical then
I'm not a roboticist sure right but to
me it's the whole team that can do that
right so some people that can actually
build the physical thing a lot of people
in this case building the software
thinking about the interaction right so
you know it's not so important to me to
answer you know whether any or all of us
are roboticist sure but what are the
people that you need to actually create
the application that your build
right definitely I definitely agree
great can you talk me through a little
bit of some of the mechanical pieces of
this of this robot in particularly so
you know mechanically we focused on
keeping this fairly so sure there's a
half-dozen motors in here okay so the
neck has left-right up-down
okay I she can move her head all around
same with the eyes left-right up-down
oh okay so the eyes have full range of
motion and then the eyelids are
independently actuated right so she can
blink at you she can wink really oh
absolutely yeah she tells you a joke she
might do that in a minute
so so fairly simple in terms of
mechanics and a lot of the things that
we think about when designing robots for
these types of applications or what are
the things that we need right we could
design something much more complex a lot
more degrees of freedom we could have
this you know so that she doesn't have
legs right she's not gonna walk around
no wheels she's not gonna no arm gesture
right no arms no manipulator it's right
because for the problems that we're
solving right for the challenges that
our patients have those things are
important right could be a fun robot if
we did that but it'd also be a much much
more expensive robot and many more
things to break yeah right so it's kind
of what are the set of things that we
actually need here right and how we
going to design those into the robot
yeah I think it's very important right
for the human robot interaction to be
able to look at a robot and have the
robot follow you look at your eyes you
know have the eyes track you have a head
track good eye contact right incredibly
important right and it's very
interesting because you could have went
with maybe just a straight head movement
right but then it doesn't feel as
realistic it doesn't feel as personal
right and that's why you need to have
the eyes be able to track independently
exactly which is very very cool so can
we wake her up yeah let's see if she's
ready here okay so you know what we can
do here is we can talk to her we can
touch the screen I guess that's good
so at this running you know it's kind of
a common demo that we show our people
and some of what you're seeing right now
might be very similar to the first
conversation that one of our patients
hears so you know right before this one
of the things that we focus on is making
this really simple for anyone to use
okay so you saw me when I walked into
the studio here do the entire setup
process that a patient has to which is a
bobble by the way yeah plug it in right
yeah that's it yeah we really thought
you were gonna need so much more we're
like a Wi-Fi use need some big cables
we're gonna make sure you get power
outlets for him you just plugged it
right in that was it and what up and
running regular outlet no Wi-Fi needed
right so these are connected through a
cellular connection so just
automatically connects the person who
gets it doesn't have to do anything
she'll introduce herself she'll ask a
few questions right there's no setup
either right it's not like there's any
menu on here there is no such thing
right there's no setup process there's
no installation process besides plugging
it in really simple for someone simply
to take her out of the box and start
talking with her right so how often is
an interaction with a patient maybe so
it depends on what we're helping a
patient with right so if we're talking
about a patient that's taking you know
some medication two or three times a day
then one to three times a day if we're
talking about patients who were helping
you know maybe manage an injection a
couple times a month and that's a bit
different right maybe what checking more
than that kind of help them you know
talk through the challenges that they're
dealing with with you know whatever
disease they're treating so it's gonna
vary right and some people are going to
want to talk to a few times a day right
we've seen this with patients who put
this with right you just want to check
in and you know say hi
right this is a kind of quick back and
forth several times a day some people
maybe a few times a week
all right so each person is different
each person has different needs in terms
of using something like this and she's
going to adapt to them to have the
appropriate level of conversation based
on that individuals needs great so can
you just come by and just have a normal
everyday style conversation with maybe
or is it more geared only towards you
know medications and check-ins or so the
way that we think about this is it's key
you're not so much about medication but
around the disease okay so we are about
to start shipping these to patients with
a couple of different conditions one is
arthritis another is a particular late
stage cancer so what we're talking about
with those patients or the challenges
around managing those particular
diseases so when we're building a new
application and we think of an
application is the intersection of a
disease and a treatment we first start
to understand okay what are the
challenges that this particular group of
patients is going to have and build up a
lot of conversations around that alright
so the medication of course that's one
piece of it but a lot of it is really
about the the symptoms of the disease
right you know arthritis patients are
having flare-ups so their arthritis
let's talk about what you can do their
side effects your medication right each
year in each decade medications get
better right many of them still do have
side effects there many people
experience right so be able to talk
about that with the patient and then
with a lot of these chronic conditions
you know we have higher rates of things
like depression or anxiety or high
levels of stress and so many
conversations about how you deal with
that as well alright so it's overall a
focus on how do we help that person
better deal with what they're doing for
a longer period of time and so those
everyday conversations are going to be
somewhere within that broad set of
topics right so it's not just gonna be
you know how's the weather right away
you know how was going out last night
with your friends for dinner right there
are some of those things in there right
but as a part of this overall
conversation of what you're doing
around your health right so it's very
it's very health centric oh yeah exactly
it's a great place to be you know I can
envision people you know particularly
elderly people or people who live alone
you know being able to say I can least I
feel like I'm talking with somebody
right I feel like I always have somebody
here as somebody who has a very old
grandfather myself right it's one of
those things that I could see like just
knowing that there's something else
there to interact what definitely kind
of helps alleviate it and it also takes
the pressure off of feeling the anxiety
I know some folks feel anxiety when they
go and visit their doctor right right
because they're worried about you know
hearing something progressing or you
know they just don't feel well and
you're a little nervous and just anxious
about the whole situation right this
kind of helps eliminate a little exact
feeling get you more comfortable and
talking with and more connected so one
of the things that's happening here is
obviously this thing is autonomous
my the conversations are being generated
as you go for that patient but you know
one of the things that we talk to
patients about is part of what's
happening here is it's getting
information that's going to go back to
your doctor or your nurse or your
pharmacist right so they know that
they're also being better connected back
to the people who are trying to provide
care for them and how do people
typically feel you know using maybe for
let's say a week or two weeks in their
home so you know I'll go back a decade
for the first version of this that was
not again not nearly as refined as bulky
robot and this was part of my PhD work
at MIT and Boston Medical right so again
ten year old technology those were not
cellular connected right so I needed the
robots back to get the data on which
turned out to be one of the biggest
challenges of running that study is at
the end of a couple of months patients
didn't want to give them back to us Wow
right right with a lot of Technology
particularly technology in healthcare
you see this rapid fall off and about
two or three weeks into it pretty much
everything gets turned off kind of like
you know I talk too much and she would
sleep right but stuff gets tossed in a
drawer or you know put in the closet
nobody uses it again no one touches it
but in that case people were still
talking to it every day it's fairly
bulky white robot at that point in time
people would dress them up right they're
wearing hats scarves I walk in one of
them have the red feather boa around its
no way that's everyone it named it all
right so you know a lot of this is
indicative of what we were seeing in
terms of the psychology behind it which
is a lot of what we think about here in
creating that engagement right so that's
really what we focus on is how do you
create that engagement between this and
the person right and so because of that
you see great outcomes after a week or a
month or even longer so what are some of
the challenges you can see moving
forward from where you are right now
maybe five ten years in the future well
you know in terms of technology that's
it's the very distant future total you
know one of the challenges that we're
focused on right now is a couple of sets
of things if we want to talk from a
technology perspective it's still
similar to what we were talking about a
few minutes ago right in that you know
integrating all these pieces is still
challenging right you know with a you
know that first version of it
very small group of people right myself
and a few undergrad students helping to
build those right today we've got a team
of about 15 people and growing but
there's still a lot of work and making
everything work well together
right and now that we're focused on you
know turning this this is not research
right this is a commercial project there
are a lot of challenges around kind of
the regulatory side of this right it's a
healthcare product in the u.s. so you
know there are things that we have to
think about and just a lot of work and
how we verify and validate and test
everything that this is doing but in
terms of kind of the underlying
technology you know we were talking a
few minutes ago about you know speech
recognition speech output getting better
every year and they are identify
definite her but it still takes a lot of
work to make it work well right right
you know her voice is perfectly
understandable but every once in a while
she'll say something that just doesn't
sound right so you got to go in and fix
that right and if you're writing all
this dialogue and you have to test it
all and make sure it sounds ok and it
all fits together and you know one of
our challenges is as we build a more and
more complex system in terms of what
this can talk about making all that mesh
together right right so that even though
any one of these parts might sound great
when we're putting it together well now
it's got to fit with everything else
that we've built right and so the system
just gets more and more complex over
time okay so talking a little bit about
what your doctor ends up seeing when you
transfer this information back what is
what has been the reception from from a
doctor side of knowing that they can
reach their patients a lot quicker they
have a lot more interaction with their
patients it's hard it's less of a
conflict to kind of schedule interview
or like numb interviews excuse me but
like appointments with your patients
what's what's the general reception that
you've seen from from the doctor side of
things so I think you know broadly
speaking where we are right now kind of
at this point in time in sort of terms
of healthcare technology in general
before we talk about this specifically
is there's you know we're getting a much
much higher rate of adoption across the
healthcare system you know both in the
US and around the world okay so I think
that there's a pretty high receptivity
to this for this specifically one of the
reasons that we have a number of
clinicians on our team is not just to
think about okay what goes in here
what's she's saying to the patient but
also how do we fit this into the overall
healthcare so straight right now the
healthcare system overall is quite
fragmented right if we think about data
and healthcare
there are a lot of challenges around
that and so what we think about doing
right now is kind of a case-by-case
integration with our customers and
partners so I talked about the first
areas that we're shipping to patients in
very soon around arthritis and cancer
we're actually partnering with the
patient's pharmacies okay so the
pharmacies are sending that drug to the
patient right now there may be making a
follow-up call or - every month to see
how they're going we're providing them
with a couple types of data feed about
what's going on with the patient so very
frequently information about something
that needs a quick follow-up right go
through a conversation she asked how I'm
feeling so not so good what's wrong I'm
not having this issue knows maybe that
that's something important gonna send
the best hey you want me to send a
message to your pharmacist to call you
I'm gonna do that right great now maybe
I'll get a call later this afternoon or
tomorrow right - follow-up but also kind
of a summary information right so some
patients are going to have things that
are at issue right now but we also just
kind of want to better track how all of
our patients are doing and if today that
means you know maybe a call every month
to check in or a visit to you know my
doctor's office every three or six
months right that's very little data
about what's going on sure what if
something happens in between that's not
serious enough that I'm going to call my
doctor
but actually it'd be good if someone
recognized that some follow-up was
needed sooner that's the kind of thing
that we're doing perfect and so thinking
through where this fits into the
healthcare system is very important so
to make sure we get a positive reception
right just throwing out data right or
saying hey we built this great new
portal but now every doctor is going to
log in - right that's not going to work
right we're never going to get that to
happen but thinking through how this
fits into the current healthcare system
is very important it's very good so if I
wanted to work at a company like Italia
what kind of skills what I need so it's
a variety I mean if we look at our
company right now you know they're a
handful of people focus on the business
side right so the sales the marketing
the legal those aspects of it the
majority of the company is focused on
product and I was talking about this a
little bit earlier you know if we think
about that our product team it's about
half people with technical backgrounds
right so artificial intelligence
robotics general software and the other
half is a mix you know writers
psychologists clinicians right so former
nurses and doctors who are helping us
build this so we really look for people
with a variety of different backgrounds
to again you put all these things
together and that's what actually makes
this work perfect great well thank you
yeah well let's go ahead and take some
questions now from our community so
let's see what we have here for you so
this first question is from the
nationally the video was very
interesting his may be already up and
running in the market I was wondering if
the project is still running with
controlled knobs meaning lab phase or
its ready to face the dynamics of humans
so this sounds like it's already being
deployed it's already being used so
we've done a lot of user testing over
the last couple of years earlier today a
first container of these came from our
manufacturing partner and so in the next
few weeks we actually start shipping to
patients very cool very very much ready
to go now be on the lookout for maybe
exactly so next question is from Bruno
Edie Santos what is the hardest part of
having a fruitful conversation between a
patient and a robot what kind of data do
you use to improve the patient's
well-being so the the answer to the
first question I think goes back to the
complexity of the kinds of things that
we want to talk about all right so one
of the limitations right now that you
see that we've kind of self-imposed here
as you saw in this conversation or the
video that was on a few minutes ago
the robots kind of driving the structure
of that conversation right so we're a
long ways from being able to do just
open-ended patient saying anything they
want I think that's one of the
challenges if we talk about big
challenges over the next five years
that's that's one of the big ones how do
we use data a bunch of different ways
okay so I talked about some of it how do
we integrate data back into the
healthcare system one of the main things
that we think about is we're constantly
building up a model of the patient in
the background actually three different
models and the one that's most unique to
what we do is what we think of as our
psychological model so looking at
different aspects of that patient from a
psychological perspective to understand
how do we best adapt the conversation
- you versus the next person versus the
next person so throughout these
conversations were always trying to
learn more right maybe it's something
very straight forward you know you're
the kind of guy who likes humor or
should you be more serious right do you
want to know like here's what you should
do or do you want to know here's what
you should do and why and how and what's
the background of the motivation and all
that right so a bunch of different
things like that that we're learning
about each patient so that we can better
tailor the conversation tonight so it's
more impactful more exactly definitely
okay so this next question is from param
Rajat poor question so they have three
questions I'm not going to overwhelm you
though I'm going to give you one at a
time one at a time does maybe use
sentiment analysis from facial
expressions as well as NLP that's a good
question actually yeah so anyway of the
camera on the front right so the camera
is there and the first thing we did with
the camera is figure out where you are
right right
she wants make eye contact sure you okay
now if we think about so we talked about
you know the the language side of things
a little bit one of the ways that we
think about what we're doing is the
stuff at the heart in terms of creating
these conversations learning about the
patient that's what we build it cuz tell
you helmet a lot of stuff around the
periphery we license from others
all right so nuance that also provides
the language and and out for Siri is
what we're using here right so they're
doing their speech recognition and
speech output
we're licensing technology from
Affectiva another media labs fed out so
actually there every one of our partners
for aimd
a memory program perfectly you can learn
some computer vision through them
through our AI program yeah so there are
a number of things like that that are
kind of around the periphery that gave
us more information about what's going
on with this person very cool so his
next question is how is the feedback
from each client used to learn and teach
me boo is the learning pipeline
semi-automatic or fully automated please
share the details about it so I don't
know how much you want to go into the
details here yeah maybe from a high
level so from a high level it's what I
was just talking about a minute ago
right a lot of the key there's around
the psychology and how we use that to
automatically adapt the conversation
sharing attention the next phase is as
we're getting data back from a lot of
patients and basically the next level up
right do some of that learn
and yeah I can't really go into too much
of the detail around the kind of things
that we're going to be doing there but
it's really about how do we look across
a lot of different patients right
understand the factors that are most
important for an individual in terms of
keeping them engaged for longer I'm
applying that to improve the
conversations right so his last question
is working on AI for healthcare for two
decades so I'm assuming this is him how
long does it take you to materialize
maybe two products actually you okay
yeah so depends on what scale you want
to look at okay so this company could
tell you he'll start a little over two
and a half years ago right okay so so
maybe the most direct answer is going
from you know the idea for this
particular thing has been about two and
a half years right right to go from
starting the company to starting the
ship to patients you know I built the
first version of what's become this 11
or 12 years ago now right when I was
doing my PhD MIT so yeah it depends on
how you want to measure and give it the
psychology behind it those studies I
started doing in 2001 so 16 years ago
yeah oh yeah so his next part he's got
to follow up all right for that question
is I also see very interesting
specialist in the team most interesting
was uh and throw more phone morphism
engineer right how is the journey been
building italia health as a team so you
know one thing you'll see when you look
at our website is you know people have
been very creative in terms of their job
titles which I love right so so kind of
going back to I think it's actually very
much relates to you know what's a
roboticist
right I don't know you ask 10 different
people in the robotics world you're
probably going to get 10 different
answers
FRS what that looks like and I think
even even much more so if you look at
the the job titles among the employees
that can Talia health which is a lot of
fun you know people kind of describe
what they do in terms of building the
team it's been great right we've found a
lot of people who have particular
expertise whether it's in you know
technology or writing or as a nurse or
as a lawyer whatever it might be but who
have a passion for the problem that
we're trying to solve right right which
is helping chronic care patients get
better care over time and so what that
means is if you look at you know the
resumes the backgrounds or the you know
the LinkedIn profiles or people it's a
really diverse group ok but if you look
at what people
are focused on that it's a very cohesive
group right I think that's super
important to have people from very
diverse backgrounds were tackling the
problem right if you get too many people
with the same background of the same
skill set you all tend to attack the
problem the same way right having people
from a very big range of skill sets and
interests really in with the dedication
and the love for a product really kind
of ties everything together nicely and
just bring some great perspective yeah I
mean about a dozen years ago 12 13 years
ago they're consulting for a number of
large electronics companies mm-hmm and
they were all in the early phases of you
know putting together groups to try to
build some application in human robot
interaction I'll leave it as very
broadly defined sure that's about as far
as they had to find it okay and go in
and give talks to these people and it
would be you know maybe 10 people on the
low end maybe 30 or 40 people on the
high end right and everyone was an
electrical or mechanical engineer all
right so in terms of like the
functioning of a robot it was awesome
right that's great guys huge teams of
engineers building it in terms of the
human interaction side not so much right
in terms of solving a real real world
problem not very good right so you have
to have that diversity right these
different views these different
approaches to something to actually
solve something and make something that
people want right great answer so this
next question is from F Khan with
respect to innovation in healthcare
especially using robotics what are some
specific areas problems that might be
easier to make an entry for a start-up
and also might be some of the hardest
areas for others so you know there's a
couple ways to think about so in terms
of specifics you know I think you know
we figured out something great right so
that has to be my first answer of course
um but but but thinking a little bit
more broadly you know one of the things
that we think about are how do we in
terms of like the structure of the
healthcare system actually change as
little as possible right right so if we
think about what we're doing at a really
high level this right the interface to
the patient she obviously very
innovative right no one else is doing
something likewise if we look at what
we're doing from a business model
perspective the type of contracts that
we put together not some of it right so
we fit into healthcare and so part of
the challenge is you know you need to
bring together part of that team
will understands existing healthcare
right if you go in and try to innovate
and change everything then you're never
going to succeed never grab maybe in 10
or 20 years right
so you know healthcare is huge right
right in the u.s. it's a three trillion
dollar a year market and so part of what
that means is you've got a lot of big
entrenched players in that space and
even if they want to change that's
really difficult right so making change
that that scale is really hard so you
have to understand how you can do
something new and innovative but also
fit it into the way that people work
today mmm
definitely I definitely agree it's yeah
it's very interesting to see that
instead of kind of redefining everything
and making a new standard the easiest
way of adaptation is actually just to
use whatever's there but make a slight
modification to it make it a little bit
better over time these things will
eventually kind of sort themselves out
which is the difference right right so
what's the real thing that you want to
focus on right because you could go in
and you can change 50 different things
when you're starting a new company right
right but that's a lot of work is or you
could change five or ten different
things that's still pretty tough what's
the one or two things that you really
need to do to succeed and make a
difference do those all right and figure
out the rest of you know how you fit
into exists it's a lot of knowing your
customers really at the end of the day
right and knowing what they'd be willing
to change what they can write right I
definitely agree so this next question
is from Edson how do you validate your
product ideas so he's got a few
questions but let's just stop at that
one for right now so combination of
things you know kind of big picture what
we're doing it's not like we could go
out and say there's something like this
in the market we're going to improve on
it right so that comes from a lot of the
core research that I've done over you
know 20 years now right in putting in
building and putting in front of
patients a lot of different types of
technology for healthcare in terms of
the specifics you know one of the things
that's important is to do user
experience testing I think that's that's
something that's been a challenge for us
as a company right because we're
building something that's that's so new
and you know at first forehand building
a few of these right so you've got a
couple of fragile prototypes you know
you carefully put those merizan one
right and now as we scale up in our
manufacturing
we can do a lot more of that but I think
you know as much as possible do
real-world testing all right so put
these in situations that are going to be
like what you're ultimately going to do
all right and then be able to you figure
out how you're going to use the feedback
from that right so not just do it but
understand what's your process for
taking that and integrating it back into
the product that you build I definitely
agree so his other follow-up question
that is how do you validate that old
sick people can use innovative
technology so you know again something
that I've done over the last 20 years
right so understanding how do you build
interfaces how to build technology that
are going to be used for a wide variety
of people right and leverage on things
people already know how to do right with
this it's conversation right I know how
to talk I know how to point I know how
to read right right so one of those
three options should hopefully exactly
right and the one thing that you see
here that's happening is you know for
output from the robot you've got
speaking and showing what she's saying
on the screen right so I can listen I
can read maybe I do both together makes
it a lot easier for responding I can
touch something on the screen I can talk
to her right so just a couple of ways to
do it so we can you know help a wider
variety of people in terms of their
familiarity their comfort their
interaction with technology to be able
to approach this very quickly and stuff
like definitely next is is your if you
rank your value propositions how
variable is facial expression feature
and does it make the product stand out
in terms of the recognition I'm assuming
since she doesn't have many features
right you know I think it's something
that's that's definitely important to us
but probably not the key to what we're
doing right the key to what we're doing
is better understanding the patient
through psychology and being able to
create conversations that adapt to that
individual right again ultimately the
outcome that we're focused on is how do
we keep that patient on therapy and out
of the hospital for longer great so this
is some questions from our YouTube live
tile right now so we have somebody says
please I need help from you Cory
I like computer science but I'm a civil
engineer and live in Egypt no way here
to study CS right now can I start to
study and work in this field so my my
guess is yes right
you can lots of great online courses
right yes yeah you have any
recommendations for human robot
interaction any any particular materials
that you like personally so I mean I
think of human robot interaction is
bringing together a handful of things
right so what I've taught human robot
interaction it either kind of a more
technical setting or in like a School of
Design right right and so people are
coming at that field even with very
different backgrounds which is you know
similar to what I'm talking about in our
company so whether that's a technical
background right and that could be more
from a software perspective sure right
so building the software the AI some
other aspects of it or from a hardware
perspective right so understanding how
to build something like this and make it
work but also from a design background
right whether that be the industrial
design of what this looks like the kind
of human factors the human interaction
side of it very important or again on
our team we've got people with you know
clinical backgrounds with writing
backgrounds I think there's a bunch of
different ways to come at this but I
think most importantly is think about
the problem that you're trying to solve
okay so human robot interaction into
themselves is also very broad sure right
there are many different ways that you
can apply that what we've been talking
about for a while now in this
conversation is healthcare which is
obviously we've been my focus on where I
apply this but you know could be
education could be entertainment there
are many other there aspects of it and
think about what you're trying to do and
then then what are the skills that you
would want in order to approach that set
of problem right definitely great so the
next question we have here is from Mike
Lynch q why would this type of robot be
better for users than a virtual person
on a computer screen so this goes back
to what we were talking about you
actually where you live minutes building
that relationship exactly right so all
comes down to basic psychology right
same reason that with a lot of
conversations that we have with other
people we prefer to do it face to face
right then over some sort of you know
video system right and and face to face
you know you're more engaged you're
creating a stronger relationship and
what we know from a psychological
perspective is that carries over into
the world of Technology right the fact
that this thing has eyes and if I just
touch your screens you'll wake up and
look at me right right that actually has
a real psychological impact right and
that's much more important being here
physically than even some
on the screen remotely you don't have
that same type of interaction exactly
whether it is actually mechanical or a
physical person yanks so much more sense
to be here / correct now some cases that
might not matter right let's say you
know telehealth right great example
where you just want to see a doctor and
solve some problem right now sure right
doesn't matter you could do it through
something like this it was scream
through the phone right but we care
about creating that relationship right
there's something that's going to go on
for weeks or months or years having that
physical thing then does start to make a
difference and it's it's really
impactful you really really see this
bond that actually happens between
humans and robots I mean there's folks I
come from the UAV space we've heard that
people have used them for reconnaissance
missions and they've been shot down
right and they've demanded burials
yeah actually for their UAVs because
they've saved their lives so many times
that they feel like this is just looking
a real connection this is a real real
entity so the next question here is from
this is Kumar luck shot button on so I
apologize for not pronouncing that
correctly hi Cory I'm an Android
developer I'm also passionate on
building stuff like robots and control
via devices so looks like two questions
so what's the course for me so basically
what would you recommend given my
background and what will I be capable of
completing when I complete robotics so
you know I'd say on the first one you
know just kind of a quick side note
about this the OS underlying this is
Android right okay definitely hire
Android developers so we also have an
Android and a degree program that you
might want to check out excellent yeah
people there all right yeah we'll be
looking for you to apply so you know I
think that you know people with good
strong software backgrounds is more
important than specifically what it is
right so get good at anything right
right and then figure out where you want
to apply that you know with robotics as
an industry taking off more and more you
see companies you know like ours and
many others hiring more and more people
with you know strong skill sets at the
intersection of robotics and something
else right right so and the robotics
again doesn't necessarily have to be the
physical robot right but an
understanding of how that applies yeah
and and so you know if you're an Android
developer that's great like that's a
skill set in demand at our company right
right and being able to do that
and then integrate that with what other
people on the team are doing to make
interesting and engaging interactions
here great great answer so the next
question excuse me is from Lilly B 423
I'd like to get into the robotics field
but I have a shaky background in
calculus and physics do any of you have
learning resources you can recommend to
get me up to speed I think we kind of
talked about this you don't necessarily
have to be a physicist
now we're an engineer or mathematician
right we're computer scientists you can
have background in psychology you can
have a background I know Nick hood from
- robotics was here a few weeks ago
you know biologically inspired robots so
having a background in biology is very
you know so yeah I mean you know find
what you are good at and what you enjoy
doing and figure out how you apply that
right right so I think what we see is
again robotics in general is being
applied in so many different industries
obviously we're talking about healthcare
here again and and some of the things
that you know that draws upon in terms
of skill sets but you know you can see
an overlap with almost any skill set
being brought to the table for
interesting robotics applications now in
in industry right agree so this next one
is from spark tang Cori what do you
believe to be the future of robots do
you believe they will have a personality
and look like us or will they become
just machines
it's actually a very interesting
question yet because there's this I feel
like there's this group that wants
everything to look ultra realistic and
then there's this other group that feels
like just this cuddly nice friendly yeah
right so when your take on this is
actually I'm really interested so it's
kind of two questions there what do they
look like it was a very philosophical
question of you know what's like us
versus what's just machine sure right
and you know I could say what what I
think we're building out over the next
five or ten years is something that
doesn't look like us right right so I
don't think that's needed you know so
there's a few aspects to this one is
just cost right there are a few robots
out there that do look fairly humanoid
sure and they're really expensive to
build now of course with all technology
that will come down and get cheaper and
cheaper but something like this is
practical today right we're shipping the
patient
this summer mm-hmm all right whereas if
I wanted to build a humanoid robot give
me five or ten years before ready to
ship that but the other goes back to we
talked about earlier with the uncanny
valley right right even if we get past
the uncanny valley look completely
human-like really depends on what's
what's that application what are you
trying to solve what more help when were
you trying to solve to do that for the
kinds of things that we're thinking
about in healthcare it's not necessary
right we don't need to confuse people
right or or convince them that this is a
person right right for what we're doing
you know something like this works
really well way so one of the arguments
for building human-like robots is it
makes the interaction more natural right
right and theoretically I can see where
people are coming from but my practical
experience in seeing you know at least
hundreds if not thousands of people
interact with something that looks like
this right is that people are really
engaged right you don't need that extra
level to create that kind of engagement
it's a very true it's very true so this
next question is from James Goldberg is
maybe using Ross if not in general what
in general to what extent have you been
able to leverage open source software so
we're not using Ross here as it talked
about we're built on top of Android so
there's there's a little bit of open
source in here probably not a ton of
things you know we're making some small
contributions to the open source
community as well including with the
motor driver board so it's a built on
top of the yo-yo board here so and we've
contributed back to the open source
community a little bit grace is like
that but a lot of what we're doing you
know the pieces that we bring from
outside are things like the speech input
and speech output and you know for
better for where's the commercial
solutions right now are much better than
the the open source solutions and the
one place we are using open source is an
open CV right right so the computer
vision system to figure out okay oh
there you are
all right look at use a lot of that I've
used open CV for that problems
absolutely right but then we're also you
know on top of that using as I mentioned
a Factiva right which is not open source
okay so so drawing from some of the same
techniques right but they've built a
platform on top of that right to give us
a lot more data there is a mix more of
it's definitely proprietary software but
and definitely like open-source
solutions and we can find them okay
great so second question is how has the
experience been with open source with
respect to making a product so so
obviously you didn't use a whole lot you
write a few libraries here there
what's the civet you've talked a little
bit about proprietary you usually better
fit your needs but what's been your
general response when you've kind of
looked at the open source software that
you've seen and said well this is great
it just doesn't fit our needs or is it
yeah it's more about you know the the
technical capabilities like something
right where we're well far enough along
in terms of understanding how we know
not all so I could tell you help but
just more broadly understanding how open
source can be used with products right
so that's something that's fairly well
understood in terms the licensing side
are things today so not really a big
issue right ten or fifteen years ago
that was not the case yeah it could be
really complex from a legal or licensing
standpoint to figure out how you make
open source work with a product but
there are a lot of people who figured
out a lot of the answers to those
questions today great so this next
question is from D gov Govender from an
evolutionary theory perspective eye
contact is an important part of
storytelling or human human
communication what other aspects of
evolutionary theory are applied to the
design of Maeby's interface or
communication system so yeah I you know
eye contact actually goes beyond even
humans right so a number of animals dogs
for example right know how to make eye
contact right so something in many
species that's one of the biggest things
that we think about here in terms of
just being able to create engagement
right now that's not creating the long
term engagement that's just the hey this
thing's looking at me I have to look
back right so there are things like that
some of the subtle gestures that you
know should use when she's talking that
that that comes away a little bit from
evolutionary theory to more kind of
modern psychology right but enabling a
number of those things in in here so
that's you know obviously right this
person saw that that was one of the key
things that were doing right okay it
looks at you right and then building a
number of layers on top of that perfect
great and I have one last question for
you please
so are you hiring absolutely you know
we're a growing company so we're about
15 people right now in
francisco and really looking across the
types of skill sets that i was talking
about you know definitely a need for
people with a variety of different
software experiences you know great if
those people have some healthcare
experience and have some robotics
experience right course right and in
understanding how these things wanted to
fit together and most importantly have a
passion for the problem that we're
trying to solve right so thinking about
how do we help people live happier
healthier lives definitely is that we
got some great people in our community
in our slack channel actually they look
forward to hearing from you be happy to
reach out and offer their expertise so
hopefully some of you out there we were
working for Catania health may be next
few months or hopefully few years down
the road when you finish your degree so
it looks like that's it for today's Q&A
if you would like to learn more about
robotics please visit udacity.com
don't forget this lion sign up for our
slack channel at robotics Udacity comm
thank you very much for your time today
it's been a pleasure thanks for having
me this is great thank you alright
[Music]